please welcome his Excellency President
SR noggin
to begin tonight's event with a
captivating song how high the moon sees
welcome just back somewhere there's
music
I
somewhere there's hair haha
love is far away till it comes to
that you love me
gives me great pleasure to welcome you
all to the president's design award
ceremony 2010 first of all let me thank
our guest owner president azzurro nardin
for honoring us with your presence this
evening and for presenting the awards to
the outstanding individuals and projects
that have made a significant impact in
the fuel of design in singapore and
across the world we will be recognizing
to designers their nine designs of the
year
you
to present the awards for tonight it is
my honor to invite on stage president s
Arnold
and
you
and now i want to invite minister mom as
well as minister Louie to visit a
memento of appreciation to the president
so like to thank my the guys with me at
asylum young Shireen and Cara we've been
working on this together for such a long
time it's been an incredible honor for
me to walk this journey review thank the
partners that we have in in the industry
such as the designing of all cancer the
singapore financial Council and all the
craftsman that have been working with us
all these years to make our meal and
exhibitions possible it is a great owner
and not only our design team but also
all the lighting designers working here
in Singapore this award is really for
everyone that has a contributor and also
supported this project for the past few
year Thank You president and design
singapore council for recognizing our
work on behalf of Jason project I give a
like to thank you for this great
opportunity I'm very proud that we are
recognized by such an esteemed award as
the oppressors design award I feel
really proud to be part of a team that
is so capable that we have an extremely
talented team here that we're working
with in this this metal this award is
really in their honor and it actually
has brought about these projects which
are getting international recognition
and under the current conditions where
projects are
procured was quite a strong track record
requirement it actually proved a barrier
to young firms are getting these
projects so maybe it's time to review
this process again and see how we can
make sure that young firms get this
chance I think we all need to take a lot
of risk to you know get good to start
design and I think you hitch to be and
finally I think my beautiful wife and
the team that waveform I think that can
I held us together for the past eight
years we survived thank you very much it
would not have been possible without the
support of the national museum of
singapore who conceptualized and brought
together the wonderful event that is a
night festival which the tree was a part
of and i like to give our heartfelt
thanks to them that is a singapore
forget me the opportunity to be a strong
foundation in order for me to further my
vision though I'm based in New York is
Singapore giving my first opportunity to
build a strong base and I will continue
to have the young generation by sharing
my experience with them and to get them
as well I'm honored to receive the
support
and after more than 30 years of having
lived and worked in Singapore
I feel as if I finally been adopted
so with gratitude I'd like to say thank
you singapore